hey Bevers I got us food
hey you were yeah anyways the door
locked behind me can you come up and
bring my kimono I'm extremely sunburned
everywhere all right
Bevers I you know cover yourself up I
don't want to see your sunburned penis
open your eyes
no it's kosher dude open them up oh my
god come on my girl got to have a proper
royal Queen Sena I'm sorry about the
bridge before I was very much processing
this all at once but then I had to leave
to set this up well this is the cutest
thing I have ever seen
but I have to change
[Applause]
[Music]
and Tre batter up happy to see you ah oh
I got you something there are few
weights thank you so much I'll try to
put on my carry-on cool right yeah yeah
I got it okay I've always said having an
incremental free weights match made in
heaven
yeah you're really special to me I be
really special oh me too well then I
guess it's now or never
Abbey Gary Anna Abrams will you marry me
Oh tray no right right yeah no yeah no
[Music]
you know no no I just figured this is my
last chance you know so um it's cool
Maria cut the video okay delete it she
said no okay well I should probably go
cuz he said no to my proposal but
promise me you'll eat for your blood
type okay
okay done alright thank you so much all
right take it enough time to show it
your rock art it's near Adonis ass it's
time to leave and exit dawg okay I was
just saying goodbye and I took up work
for this dude that sucks you know what
else sucks when your best friend moves
away and everybody's out for Faceman for
getting out of here
but maybe we'll be friends I don't mmm
supporters go it
[Music]
I'm gonna miss you I'm gonna miss you
too like how's a lot of door I haven't
talked through yet um yeah Ilana is uh
you know I was gonna be great
looks like it okay no get out go go what
are you Abby's friend
Hey hi thank you for inviting me yeah
you're welcome
you're Abby's friend too you know we're
no longer dating right and we're gonna
keep growing our real yet platonic
friendship and that means honesty so I'm
I'm gonna be honest with you you gotta
get the out of here
yeah it's time to go yep I heard about
grad school Jaime told me I wanted to
congratulate you yeah you're a good guy
beyond oh great party's over bitch you
know I know it's kitty you know moving
away but it's good to remind ourselves
of this other places besides New York
City beautiful places in New Jersey it's
gonna be great yeah sad okay um they're
people from your building I just needed
to fill the party out can't wait for
brunch next week in Jersey City is
pretty damn lit mm-hmm yes it is go now
though soon to leaves to exit and leave
good to see enters the way love yeah
hi guys thank you someone who are coming
you can leave I'm dumb okay so the exit
is that way yeah
[Music]
okay I'm almost here what else here now
we can connect well I'm gonna stay at my
own place tonight I'm gonna give you two
broad some privacy and I have a present
for you you need to get me anything
oh well it's just so you could store
your cheese in here everyone will know
whose cheese it is and they won't be
able to take it from you anymore I love
it it's perfect and we'll see each other
again yeah
all right Hey brunch at Felix tomorrow -
and then a movie my choice clear your
schedule bitch
thanks for the party my pleasure
[Music]